Munich: The Edge of War
is the story
of two young men
embroiled in one of the most
crucial moments
in 20th century history.
Adapted
from Robert Harris' novel,
the film is set
in the autumn of 1938,
as the British Prime
Minister desperately tries
to broker a peace.
As long as war
has not begun,
there is always hope
that it may be prevented.
Meanwhile,
one of his civil servants
connects with
an old German friend,
carrying an all
important document
that could change
the course of history.
Don't look at it,
just put it under your arm,
-God damnit.
-Right.
-Make a terrible spy, Hugh.
-Sorry.
While the film
and the book are fiction,
they are rooted
in real events in history.
So, let's take a look
at the true story
behind
Munich: The Edge of War.
Adolf Hitler rose the power
in the latter half
of the 1930s
and was determined to invade
neighbouring countries
to reclaim
lost German territories.
Having already marched
into Austria,
Hitler, set his eyes
on Czechoslovakia,
specifically,
the Sudetenland,
which bordered Germany,
and where
many Germans lived.
The Czech government
at the time
was against annexing
these borderlands
to Germany.
Meanwhile, the British
and French were intent
on avoiding another war
and adopted a policy
of appeasing
Hitler's Germany.
It was then Prime Minister
Neville Chamberlain,
portrayed by Jeremy Irons
in the film,
who took the lead
on the growing crisis.
He met with Hitler
a total of three times.
The first,
on 13th September, 1938,
at Hitler's residence
in Berchtesgaden.
The second took place
in Bad Godesberg
on the 24th,
resulting in
the Godesberg memorandum,
which demanded
that Czechoslovakia
give up
the Sudetenland to Germany
by 28th September.
If they did not agree,
Hitler threatened
to take the territories
by force.
Mere hours
before the deadline passed,
Chamberlain managed
to convince Italy's leader,
Benito Mussolini,
to enter the negotiations
and urge Hitler
to delay any hostilities.
If Herr Hitler is not
going to listen to me,
maybe he'll listen
to his great friend,
Benito Mussolini.
Hitler agreed to a delay
and an emergency meeting
between Britain, France,
Germany, and Italy
was set for 29th September
in Munich.
Even though this meeting
was about Czechoslovakia,
their government
had no input.
As we see in the film,
Chamberlain received news
of this conference
from his personal secretary
while he was
addressing parliament.
I am able to report
to the House,
that I have just
received news from Berlin
that Herr Hitler
has postponed mobilisation.
Given the urgency
of the situation,
it's not surprising
this meeting
did not take long
to reach a resolution.
As pictured here,
those in attendance
included Chamberlain,
Hitler, Mussolini,
and French Prime Minister
Édouard Daladier.
In the small hours
of 30th September,
the Munich Agreement
was signed,
agreeing
to German occupation
of the Sudetenland,
as well as de facto control
of the rest of the country,
on the agreement
Hitler would go no further.
Which, we know now,
was not
what he intended to do.
Czechoslovakia
had no option but to accept,
knowing they could not fight
the Nazi army
without the support
of Britain or France.
Shortly after the Munich
Agreement was signed,
Chamberlain
approached Hitler
to sign
a non-aggression statement,
symbolic of the desire
of the two countries
to never go to war
with one another again.
I want him
to publicly commit himself
to peace.
The news
of a diplomatic resolution
was met with relief.
with Europe still scarred
by the First World War,
then known as the Great War,
the prospect
of another conflict
weighed heavily
on the leaders of the time.
I fear
for the spiritual wellbeing
of our people,
if they don't see
their leaders
doing everything,
absolutely everything,
to prevent another conflict.
As Chamberlain
returned to London,
waving
the non-aggression pact
signed by himself
and Hitler,
it seemed
like war had been averted.
He was met in London
with scenes of jubilance,
cheered by thousands
as he arrived
at Buckingham Palace
to give a first-hand report
to King George VI.
Chamberlain later addressed
a similarly cheering crowd
from a second floor window
at Number 10,
declaring, "I believe
it is peace for our time".
But that wasn't the case.
By March, 1939,
Hitler had annexed
the rest of Czechoslovakia
and in September
the Nazi army
marched into Poland.
The next time Chamberlain
addressed the country,
it was to call
for a declaration of war
against Germany.
Shortly afterwards,
he was forced to resign
and was replaced
by Winston Churchill.
While the Munich Declaration
went on to be seen
by many
of Churchill supporters
as an unnecessary
appeasement of Hitler,
some historians have argued
Chamberlain bought
much needed time
to bolster
British military defences
by delaying the war.
Either way, the war
Chamberlain sought to avoid
did eventually come to pass.
To find out how
this pivotal moment
in history pans out
for the characters
of Munich: The Edge of War,
make sure
you catch the movie
now streaming on Netflix.